So if you would just start by introducing yourself to Snow, your name and date date and
where we got, I know.
Okay.
I'm Christopher Matthews.
Today is September 2nd, 2011 and we're in the Valley Memorial Library.
Okay.
So, first of all, where are you born and what are you up?
I was born in 1937 in New York City and my father was about to start a medical practice in
the Bridgeport, Connecticut.
So we moved from New York very early.
He was stationed with a Navy during the war on a variety of places and moved to Seattle in
1944 and the family moved with him after my family moved back to Connecticut again, but
after three years they realized they'd made a big mistake leaving the West Coast.
So we moved to Olympia in 1949 and that's what I consider my hometown.
But what's some of your hobbies when you're growing up?
Well, it's pretty interesting science obviously.
I had a chemistry set and my friends and I used to make rockets and fire them off.
And it became interested in birding a nature study because my grandfather was a professional
ornithologist who was cured of birds at the American Museum of Natural History in New
York.
So we had, we were very much exposed to natural history all my life.
And that's kept on.
I was president of the Autobahn Society of Corp.
Allows for three years.
So there was a strong family influence in the scientific and the fact that I understand
where that early interest in science came from?
Right.
You're family.
Well, yes, my grandfather of course was an ornithologist and a very broadly based biologist.
My father was a physician and his father was a surgeon.
So there wasn't, well, let's say there was both medical and scientific achievement in
our background.
And people who does natural, I guess, for me to have a career in science, although I
did consider medicine pretty strongly at various times.
My mother?
She has a degree from Vassar in English and actually dramatic production.
And she never got involved in science, but she obviously encouraged what my brother
and my sisters and I did.
My brother ended up as a wildlife biologist and retired a few years ago from the University
of Washington faculty in the College of Fisheries.
My sisters are all younger and they, two of them finished college, but they finished
in their 30s.
My parents went through a fairly messy divorce when my sisters were teenagers and I think
this kept them from being motivated to go through college, but they were all very bright
and they went back.
And they had achieved quite a lot actually.
My youngest sister, among other things, has published three books, one of which was
described her experience as the winner of the Pillsbury Bake Off in 1998, with a $1 million
prize.
It's a very readable book.
Very interesting.
So outside of your family, where there are other scientific mentors or influences in your
life, every child?
I guess so.
I hadn't thought very much about that, but not so much toward the hard science.
In fact, the chemistry course that I took in high school was probably my least favorite
course.
Although the teacher, Mr. Gaines, was my merit badge counselor when I got the chemistry
merit badge in Boy Scout.
This is my freshman year in high school and he told me I shouldn't try for it until I
was a junior and had taken chemistry and he helped me through it.
But he wasn't a very good teacher.
The botany teacher, Mr. Burke also, and the physics teacher, Mr. Keller, none of them
I thought were particularly good teachers, but there was enough interest in what I was
doing and that I guess that provided some motivation.
So you were scouting with something to be involved in?
Yes.
When we moved to Olympia, we lived in the right in town, actually about two blocks from the
state capital building and it was very easy to be in Boy Scouts and my parents bought
some waterfront land about seven miles out of town and we moved there to a house that
they built in my freshman year.
And it became much more difficult to be involved in scouting after that.
So although I always wanted to be an eagle scout, I just drifted out of it.
How would you characterize the rest of your high school experience?
That's an interesting question too.
I had to skip the second grade so I was younger and smaller than most of my classmates
and it took me a while to catch up socially, but I worked pretty hard at it and ended
up with a very nice group of friends.
I thought that educationally the high school experience was pretty mediocre, but maybe
I was too hard on it.
I worked pretty hard and obviously did pretty well.
My daughter managed to make it through Corvallis High in three years and when I thought back
on my high school experience, maybe that would have been good, but then I would have been
two years ahead and the catching up socially would have been that much more difficult.
Any sports in the Anthropocies?
I've never been very athletic but I've enjoyed doing things.
I've been a seed cross-country skied and I jog regularly and you wouldn't call that
athletics, but it's keeping in shape.
Played a little tennis but it never was very good as much of anything in a way of sports.
Okay, so after high school you went to read college?
How did you decide to go to the...
I was reading an article on the Saturday evening post in 1952, my junior year in high school
and there was an article by Richard Newberger who later became a senator from Oregon and
the title of the article was The School for Bright Young Things.
I guess that's sort of what I perceived myself as and I'd never heard of where he called
before even though he lived just 120 miles away from Portland.
It looked like a pretty exciting place and it seemed as though it would be right for
me and so I applied to read and I applied to Stanford and of course it was accepted both
places and read just seemed much more convenient and it was more affordable.
Quite a different... quite a distinction between the two alternatives because our son eventually
went to Stanford so I learned a lot more about it.
I assume that you mentioned being some of this aspect of the academic high school read
probably presented a different sort of new version.
Yeah, actually three of us from my graduate class went to read and one of them only made
it two years.
The other one who'd been a very strong science student ended up majoring in philosophy
and going to law school and also becoming an extremely accomplished folk musician.
He and his wife basically made their living.
So read was interesting in terms of the fact that a lot of people went there moving in
one direction and changed directions completely or undirected them and getting a direction.
There was also a very high attrition rate then so there were a number of students that
went there undirected and there wasn't much supervision and so a number of students
had dropped out and I was one of the ones who had a sort of vague idea of what I wanted
to do and basically stayed with it.
What was the climate like in the day?
I suppose pretty much like it is today.
It was pretty intense intellectually but the students knew how to do it however good time
as well.
The academic environment was very strong.
The courses in liberal arts and social science all had a very heavy writing component.
So in the freshman humanities course we had to write a paper every week and then we had
an individual conference about every paper with the instructor.
So anything any credit I can take for my ability to write today I order e-college and
the science was very strong also.
At that time in the early mid-50s I would say that the science wasn't as strong as it
is currently.
Read like many of the other high quality undergraduate colleges has really made a push for a stronger
research orientation in the science faculty and although we were all required to write
a thesis when I was a student I would say the thesis worked all cutting-edge science
but put it that way.
In fact one of my regrets about read was that I probably took more science than I really
needed to and I should have taken more courses in liberal arts philosophy and literature
and social sciences than I did but I ended up with the interest in a lot of different
areas and I learned a lot of things through my own reading and that's what college is
supposed to be for anyway I think.
How would you say you're assigned as a dentist developer than the graduate?
Well I went there as a chemistry major because probably because of my interest that started
with the reading about chemistry and playing with chemistry sets and so forth so it was
sort of an unfocused interest but at some point I read a science fiction anthology of short
stories and the stories were grouped by a scientific area that the science fiction dealt with and
so there were two or three stories that were listed under biochemistry and I never heard
of biochemistry before and I thought hey the idea of chemistry that has something to do
with biology I'm going to have to read these stories and I enjoyed them and so my junior
year I took a biochemistry course and the reading I did both in class and auto class convinced
me that this was a pretty exciting area to go into.
During my sophomore year I'd wrestle with the idea of going to medical school.
I had a hard time with organic chemistry the first term of it and the first in the fall
term of my sophomore year and I'd like to tell medical students or pre-medical students
this story.
I began to wonder if I was bright enough to go into science and maybe I should go into
medicine instead but then the second semester or the main course for majors was quantitative
analysis and I did much better and at the end of the year I decided I was bright enough
to go into science after all.
What's it have or you're reading or maybe even your high school you told me a story
about a letter that you are doing very well and it's falling?
I first heard of Linus Pauling the fall semester of my freshman year in chemistry class one
day there was a student who raised his hand to ask a question and he said oh professor
does what you're talking about have anything to do with the Pauling theory of resonance
and professor Lumeur gave him a very respectful answer and I thought to myself I've never
heard of Pauling but I guess I'd better learn something about this guy and then remarkably
enough within the next two or three weeks it was announced that Linus Pauling had won
the Nobel Prize in chemistry so I realized that this student was a little bit ahead of
me in terms of knowing major scientific themes.
You've been a letter letter in there and that's fine?
Right I guess you and I talked about that a few years ago you want me to describe that
for the Oregonian published an editorial a day or two after the Nobel Prize was announced
and it was basically congratulations to a native son of Oregon who went on and achieved
the great things and won the Nobel Prize but wasn't it the same about his inaccurate thinking
and his political association that had led him to have his passport lifted and I thought
it was pretty inappropriate to bring these political things into at a time when we should
be celebrating this person's intellectual triumph and so I wrote my first letter to the
editor ever and at that time Reed College was in very bad odor in the Portland area
because the Velley Committee which was the House on American Activities Committee had
toured the country in the spring or just before I started college and three members of the
Reed faculty were interviewed and refused to discuss their associations and this made
a lot of people think that Reed was full of confidence so when I wrote the letter to the
editor I used my home address from the look here which could be seen as being within the
readership area of the Oregonian and then I guess I clipped the editorial and my letter
and mailed them home to my mother and because my grandparents knew the Paulings my grandfather
was a member of the American Philosophical Society which Pauling was also my mother mailed this
to my grandmother and my grandmother mailed it to Pauling and Pauling eventually sent me
a nice short note which pleased me a great deal Pauling's youngest son and Craylon was a
classmate of mine at Reed and then later on when I was a graduate student at the University of
Washington and my wife was a graduate student in genetics Craylon Pauling was doing his
graduate work in genetics also so Cate and Craylon worked in the same lab and we used to see them
socially fairly frequently so somehow or another I had a fairly close series of relationships
with the Pauling family. I'm sorry? Yeah he was pretty immature and he had a great sense of
humor he seemed to enjoy life a lot he started as a chemistry major at Reed and he didn't do
very well so he switched to biology and it took him five years to graduate so he started
graduate school at UW a year after I had and then I think it took him five or six years to finish
his PhD but he actually published some fairly important papers from his postdoc and then later on
when he was on the faculty at San Francisco State as far as I remember right he was he was chair
of the biology department there for quite a few years and so he was always a very likeable fellow
and he was unsubbatical here in 1980 and 81 he worked with Dick Morita in the microbiology
department and his then second wife K Pauling worked in our department as a postdoc with one of
my colleagues so we reestablished contact down it was very pleasant. I didn't know anything.
Well there was kind of an amusing this doesn't have anything to do with college
era but during that year that that Krell and Pauling was here I was called upon to be the
organizers of the what used to be the annual biology colloquial I'm not even sure if that's
still held so I organized the two-day meeting on the on the organization and manipulation of
genetic information this is 1981 and we had a party for the speakers and the people who
were participating and the president McVickire was at the party and he came up to me and he said
Chris I'd like to have you introduce me to to winus Pauling Sun so I took him over and introduced
him to Krell and he backed Krell and into a corner and wouldn't let him out and they were
talking there for probably 20 minutes I was trying to think of a way that I could rescue Krell and
Sun but it didn't work. So did you have any mind? With
the line of spalling? Yes probably the first time I met him
he came to Seattle for a lecture and I met him there so that would have been in 1961
when I was a student but then my first month here I started my employment as chairman of
biochemistry and biophysics in January 1978 and one of the first things I learned in my first
week on the job was that I had to get ready for site visit for our department because the
legislature in the previous year had had made some sort of a budget note or order of some kind
that there should be reviews of academic programs that might involve duplication between Oregon
state and the U of O and although the U of O didn't have a biochemistry department they had the
institute of molecular biology and they had a biology department and a chemistry department so
chemistry and biochemistry were getting reviewed and Linus Pauling was one of the outside reviewers
that was brought in and it was fairly intimidating so I had to prepare for a day long site visit
I've forgotten who the other reviewers were and then we had a similar experience we were
site visit as a biology department as well so I had to organize two site visits and I remember
the biology site visit one of the one of the site visitors was Herschel Roman who was professor
genetics at the UW and he's the one that my wife worked for and one of the other site visitors
was a guy named Gordon Lark who was at Kansas State University who's quite a prominent bacterial
geneticist and when he met with me early in the morning he said Chris why did you move here anyway
and it's sort of a sort of a wondering what the what the deal was what was the attraction
because I had a pretty good job at the University of Arizona before I moved here
and then later in the day when I met with him again and they'd had a chance to talk a lot
of the people and learn about Oregon State he said you don't have to answer me anymore he said
now I know why you moved here so I felt pretty good about the decision I had made to move
when that happened that gets over away from Linus Pauling but I met him two or three times
when he when he came to the campus either for the annual award of the Pauling Medal
or for other other things somehow we were brought into contact so I probably met him half
dozen times did I ever tell you the story about Pauling on the joke that he told at the Pauling
do you want to hear that it gets a little bit out of the chronology so the three north western
sections of the American account for society given the Linus Pauling Medal every year
and jointly and there's symposium on a banquet and the the the locale moves around from
Corvallos to Seattle to Pullman Washington or wherever and in the fall of 1979 it was held here
and so Pauling used to come to all these and after the banquet then he would give a little talk
about what he'd been doing during the previous year these things were always hugely entertaining
and so the talk of the day of the 1979 and Mrs. Pauling was with him she was still alive then
he said that he was encountering a lot of skepticism about vitamin C and the reporter was interviewing
I mean he said now Professor Pauling you take vitamin C don't you and well of course I do
young man well then sir do you mind if I ask you a few questions about your state of vigor no go
right ahead well sir can you tell me then please when did you have your last sexual experience
well I looked at him and I said why 1956 and he said well that's terrible you know I said
what's so terrible about it you know you look at his watch and say it's only 2210 now
okay well we mentioned Washington and Man Seattle how do you make this decision to go to
the country okay that's a good question too in the in the summer of 1957 I went back to visit my
grandparents in Long Island and they were very interested in having me go to graduate school in the
East Coast so they took me to visit various schools Harvard and Brown and John's Hopkins but one
thing that I did since they lived fairly far out on the island they'd arranged a visit for me at
Brookhaven National Laboratory and I met with a biochemist there named Robert Steele and he told
me about what he was doing and he said I don't know why you're looking at all of these
graduate schools in the East Coast when one of the best graduate schools in the country is right
out for your living I said what's that and he said well the University of Washington it's a new
department but it's really good so I figured well like I said better look at it and so I ended up
applying to vertically John's Hopkins and the University of Washington and in those days
1954 no excuse me 57 58 you didn't get flown the departments to be interviewed at their expense
I had visited John's Hopkins I never did go down to the Cal but I was home for the weekend and
drove up to Seattle and the department was small it had just seven faculty members but they were
really nice and they and they represented a nice cross section of the biochemist through that
era and they all had good records of academic achievement and you know it was pretty close to my
family all living in the state of Washington at the time and so I figured why not and worked out
pretty well well I was pretty on focus when I began graduate school I when one my fellow students
would ask me what are you interested in I'd scratch my head and I'd say well I guess I'm
interested in enzymes but I'd like to do some project in enzymes that has potential applications
in medicine or biology what have you and so we were required to talk to all the faculty
about their research and Frank Honeckins was doing work on folate and simology so folate is one
of the B vitamins and it's converted to a coenzyme tetrahydrofolate and tetrahydrofolate is a
coenzyme that mobilizes single carbon functional groups and so these are involved in methylation
for example methylation of DNA methylation of certain amino acids and proteins and also the
methyl group of thymine nucleotides that get into DNA and the Honeckins laboratory had just recently
shown that that the action of methotrexate which is a folate analogue used in cancer treatment
he was discovered in the 1940s it's a very potent adylychemic agent that had acted by inhibiting
an enzyme called dihydrofolate productase that reduces folate to tetrahydrofolate and I thought
this was really interesting there wasn't very much known about the enzyme at the time but the fact
that the enzyme was a target for a very effective drug meant that the this whole area of folate
enzymology had the kind of protein enzyme focus that I was interested in with potential
applications of significant stymetres and so so I went to work with the with Frank Honeckins
and it worked out pretty well for me he was one major professor one of the other reasons that I
was interested in his lab was that I learned that he'd had several students who'd managed to
finish their PhDs and fairly short order and I was interested in getting my PhD and moving on
and that worked out pretty well too uncompleted by PhD requirements in a little under three and a half
years which is pretty fast by by today's standards where PhD had generally a five-year program or
so well as you when you were at the University of Washington working at PhDs you got many.
That's what you got married that's what you're asking?
Yeah that's an interesting one too because my wife was a graduate school classmate in biochemistry
there were 12 entering students in the class of the entering class of 1958 and we ended up as
lab partners in the lab course and then later in the year as teaching assistants we were assigned
together to the to the reagent room that was called the solution room making up reagents for the
biochemistry lab class for dental students and we were supposed to put in 10 hours a week
effort in our TA duties and we worked pretty efficiently together so I think maybe we worked two or
three hours each per week and we didn't see each other socially at all at the time she had a
bunch of other boyfriends and I think we both had the feeling that you didn't get involved with people
that you saw every day but her interests were more biological and the genetics department was
founded in the spring of 1959 so she transferred to genetics so in our second year
when we were not seeing each other every day it became a little bit more natural and so we got married
in the spring of the early summer of 1960 and it's kind of interesting because Kate grew up in
Berkeley her mother was a research technician in the virus lab she worked for Wendell Stanley who
wanted a Nobel Prize for his work in tobacco mosaic virus and at Berkeley the virus lab and the
biochemistry department were in the same building at the time and Kate's mother tended to mother all the
graduate students who were unattached so if I'd gone to Cal as a graduate student we've always wondered
whether whether Elsa would have sort of the mothered million picked me out of someone suitable for
her daughter and would have got us together and we had a laugh over that over the years but
you can only live one life at a time. He also had your first child as a doctor on 28.
Right that wasn't planned. Lawrence was born maybe nine and a half months after we got married
and the drank champagne from a glass on our first wedding anniversary and so Kate never finished her
PhD and she claims I had various times I encouraged her to do it she worked as a lab technician
and she also worked when I was at Yale she worked as a as a teaching assistant in the
department of biology where I was and she always claimed that she really didn't want a PhD anyway
she loves working in a lab and she's pretty good at it but she says she's good at the tactics but not
so good at the strategy at developing a long range line of research and a lot of learning for
funding and that sort of things so I think she's pretty happy with the kind of careers she had.
Was it difficult to sort of maintain an household and also be sort of related to a
program recently? Yeah well somehow it worked.
I a lot of my fellow students would go back
to work in a lab in the evening and I just stay home and Kate was very good about
after Lawrence was born about seeing that I had a couple of quiet hours every
every evening and I don't remember what's sitting around you but she was still working as a
graduate student in the teaching assistant in the genetics department somehow it seemed to work.
Okay so you finished up your PhD and you did a post-doc and
you know I wrote a bit about that? Yeah by the time I was approaching finishing my PhD
I knew that I wanted to work in a biological system that had more potential for genetics. I was
getting more involved in the biological side of insomology than the chemical or biophysical side
and reading the literature. I selected three people whose work I was interested in
and I wanted to be able to go to a lab where the specific experience that I'd had of the graduate
student would be useful and so Seymour Cohen at the University of Pennsylvania was the one I eventually
settled on and he was working on bacteria phases, bacterial viruses and basically in the late
1940s when he started with his own lab he'd done what I would call the first biochemical experiments
on what happens metabolically during a virus infection cycle using phages, model systems for
plant or animal viruses which of course were much more difficult to work with biochemically
at that time and in the early 1950s he and a postdoc had shown that DNA from
certain bacteria phases had a very unusual modification in that all of the cytosine
residues and DNA were modified by having a hydroxyl methyl group and then on the mid to late
1950s they'd shown the biochemical basis for this that there were new enzymes that were induced
after a virus infection that put on the hydroxyl methyl group and that phosphorylated the nucleotides
getters at the point where it could be activated and incorporated in the DNA. So the whole idea that
virus infection stimulated pneumatobolic pathways was really exciting to me and this ends on to put on
the on the the hydroxyl methyl group had a tetrahedral folate cofacture so it meant that I could
bring some biochemistry to Cohen's lab that would be that would be that would help him out and it
was it was nice pairing but again in those days so now we're talking 1961 you didn't just hop
on a plane to visit every lab that you were going to consider for a postdoc so I wrote to three people
and I was going to give a paper at the Federation meeting in 1960 in April 1961 this is the
Federation of American Societies for Experimental Biology which at that time included societies
for biochemistry, physiology, pharmacology, nutrition and a couple of others and it was the big
meeting for biochemists to go to and so the three people that I was considering would be at the
meeting and I could meet with them there. This happened very shortly after Lawrence was born so
I really located that a gratitude and also my mother and Kate's mother and my grandmother
who all came in and helped out but I was able to go to the meeting and meet with them and it was
kind of amusing because on the first day of the meeting I met Seymour Cohen for the first time
and apparently my major professor who had sent a letter of recommendation sent a two-page letter
and I didn't learn this to later but the second page of the letter to Cohen had Dr. Boyer's
name at the top of the page and so Seymour knew that I was considering more than one laboratory
and he had recently had someone very good who had accepted a postdoc and then went somewhere else
and said so almost as soon as I shook hands with Seymour and introduced myself he said now see here
if I accept you and my laboratory are coming or aren't you and so it really set me off and I
wondered who is this guy anyway but then I met the other two people during that week and by the end
of the week I decided I wanted to work with Seymour so I had another appointment with him and almost
before I had a chance to say anything he said well I've decided I'd like to have you come and
join my lab and I said well that's funny I decided I wanted to join your lab too and then he
insisted on driving me to Philadelphia this is Atlantic City which is about 60 miles from Philadelphia
so I could see his lab and meet the other people which I did and that was very nice because then
I knew them all by the time I joined his group six or eight months later.
So from there you was on the Yale. How did that fund up and what was it like being a brand new
member at Yale? Things were much different back then. I used to get unsolicited offers of assistant
professorships they're not supposed to know offers I get a letter in the mail from the department
chairman that would say would would you like to apply for an assistant professorship in our
department and Seymour Cohen would come into the lab on occasion with letters do you like to
that you they they want me to recommend someone for this place of that place would you like to apply
most of the time I said well no and but Yale was interesting my my father had worked at the Yale
Medical School after the war back on in that interval between our lives and washing and
state and then I knew Yale was a pretty good place and so I I told Seymour he could go ahead and
to put my name in if he'd like but I told him I really hope to get back to the west coast
and he said well fine I'll write to a couple places where already like me to write and I said well
UC Davis has the new biochemistry department that's pretty good you could write to that and also
the University of Oregon has this new institute of molecular biology they has from two other people
there so he wrote to both places and they both wrote back and said they had positions and they were
interested and I should send my CV and so forth which I did and the meantime then I was invited
up to Yale to be interviewed and it was an interesting day I gave the seminar at noon and then I met
immediately after the seminar with the search committee and they gave me a lunch date which I
was trying to eat at the same time I was trying to answer questions it was it was pretty stressful
and one of the search committee members took me to the train at the end of the day and I went back
to Philadelphia and he said he said well we have to go through a series of steps before we can
make a decision on the anything but so maybe a while before you hear from us again and I thought
well that's fun I'm not to hurry anyway because I want to see what develops at Davis and Eugene
but within a week I had a letter from them saying that the the search committee had met and they
decided they were going to recommend that I get the appointment and so forth and eventually I did
get a formal offer of a letter and I sort of stalled them as long as I could and finally it was
it was a good offer the salary was pretty poor by comparison with what my cohort was getting at
other places but it was the biology department I didn't consider myself so much in biologists but
they were trying to build up biochemistry and molecular biology within the department they wanted
me to set up a lab class in biochemical research techniques that their graduate students could take
said that was a bit of a challenge anyway I accepted the job on on on Monday and then I
wrote to the department chairs at Eugene and Davis and then on Thursday the phone rang in the lab
and I took the call it was the department chair at the view of O and he said oh Dr. Masey we just
got your letter and we're terribly disappointed we we got your last recommendation and the
fact we've had a meeting we decided you'd be ideal for the job we were about to invite you to come
out and give a seminar can we get you to change your mind and I you know I said I'm sorry I
made a commitment and that was that and then I went home thinking I guess I'd give it up my last
chance to go to a good university in the Pacific Northwest and who would have known what happened
years later so I went to Yale in starting in January 1964 and today's assistant professors of course
got almost the first year without significant teaching responsibilities to set up their lab
and the very first thing I had to start setting up to teach this lab class that was
beginning the end of the well the beginning of the spring semester which was the end of January or
the early February and I had ordered almost everything I needed but but a teaching assistant and I
had to set up the lab I had to write the the protocols for all the labs that the students would do
this is a class of 15 students so I was very busy with teaching on the other hand I also had my
NIH research grant that started on January 1st grants were incredibly easy to get back then
and so I was buying equipment and hiring a technician and getting my research labs set up
at the same time it was sort of a continuation of what I'd done as a postdoc one of the things
this is actually kind of an amusing story too the thesis my PhD thesis had been on the
enzyme dihydrofolate reductase which I told you was the target enzyme for metatruxate and there
was another lab that had shown the enzyme that makes the methyl group of thymine reduces a
methylene group to the methyl level that requires two electrons and the rate of DNA synthesis after
T4 phage infection goes up by about 10 fold which means there's a tremendous demand for DNA
precursors including thymine nucleotides and so since there's a two electron reduction
it turns out that the tetrahedral folate is oxidized to dihydrofolate and so when I became
aware of all this and I was talking to CMR Cohen one day on the lab and I said you know with this
big increase in demand for thymine nucleotides there are all these virus induced enzymes that you
and the other labs have been discovering we should be looking for dihydrofolate reductase there
there should be a virus specific form of dihydrofolate reductase as well I know how to
ask the enzyme I worked on it for my PhD you so as I go ahead and do that and he said why didn't you
focus on the problem that we agreed that you would work on when you came to the lab and I said okay
and then CMR was out of town for three days or so and I did the experiment and there was a
24-old increase in the specific activity of dihydrofolate reductase and in a T-fage in fact
itself is compared to uninfected cells and it turned out to be really easy to show that it was
a it was a different enzyme from the corresponding enzyme that existed in the uninfected bacteria so
one of the things I did we got a short paper out of it but one of the things that I did when I
went to Yale was just a it was golden opportunity to get a free paper we just purified the enzyme
and characterized it make mutants that were deficient in the production of the enzyme to see
what their phenotype was and so forth so there were a number of problems related to DNA precursor
metabolism early in infection by T even pectuary vagis that got me off to a pretty decent start
and I published six or eight papers in the first couple of years I was in Yale even though I had a
pretty heavy teaching load. So you were in Yale for four years definitely? Roughly, you got
actually three and a half by the calendar but they started my appointment as assistant professor
in July of 1963 and I was in absentia for the first half year and then I taught that lab class
and then in the fall they had me set up a lab for the what was an undergraduate cell biology course
which was basically biochemistry in the fall semester and cell biology and the spring semester
so a colleague and I shared the fall course where he did most of the lecturing I taught the lab.
Did your research in the change of the course you had kind of yellow or something specific with that
same topic? Oh, about the research? Yeah. Yeah I say pretty much with that I was branching out a
little bit more biologically and looking at questions such as the regulation, the time-specific
regulation of gene expression, virus infection involves a very well scheduled program of events
in gene activation and deactivation and so I was interested in what turns off the biosynthesis
these are really enzymes that are involved in DNA metabolism and then the activation of the
late proteins which are mostly structural proteins of the virus and proteins that help the virus
assemble so I was pretty much sticking with what I knew but branching out in slightly different
directions. What was your sense of the culture of Yale? Yeah that's an interesting question too.
It was all male of course as far as the undergraduate student body was concerned. There was a
fair amount of self-satisfaction. The undergraduate students were really bright, at least enough of them
were really bright to make it worth the effort to teach them to make it fun. The graduate students
seemed like kind of a mixed lot to me. I wasn't hugely impressed to them at the time except for some
of the very good ones and what's turned out in retrospect is that I maybe was a little bit too
hard of them because a number of the graduate students that I thought were okay have turned out to have
very successful careers. I see their names in the literature all the time so I guess the students
were, they were as good as they thought they were but in terms of the culture my decision to leave
Yale after a fairly short period there. I knew when I went there I wouldn't have my whole career
there. I didn't really want to live in the East Coast. I knew that most people would take
non-tenger jobs at the Indian Ivy League move somewhere else and I thought it was a great place
to start from. I might not have left so early but we had a new department chair who came from
Johns Hopkins and he was a fairly argumentative sort. He was someone who always wanted to put
himself on the, he wanted to polarize discussions and so in my last year at Yale the other biochemist
in the department had gone on sabbatical and no arrangements had been made to take his place so
so I was giving all of his lectures and the cell biology courses as well as teaching the lab
in the fall and then teaching the graduate lab in the spring. In addition I'd become a pre-medical
advisor so I had several dozen advisees that I had to meet with and write letters of recommendation
for and I was being run ragged and trying to keep my research going as well. So there was a social
function and I went out to the department chair. There was a large department there about 45
people in the department so he'd be barely new and I engaged in a conversation and I asked
what are your thoughts about teaching versus research in an academic environment and he said
well of course you had to be a good teacher if you wanted to succeed at Yale but the main objective
was research. He said if you want to say at Yale your research must settle it, it must absolutely
send away and if you ever want to be a full professor at Yale in this department you have to be
someone that we can confidently number among the top 50 biologists in the country. So I went home
and I figured with the amount of teaching and committee work I was doing there wasn't any chance
of my rising to the top 50 and then I also looked around the department and I didn't see very many
full professors that I would rank in the top 50 myself there were one or two. So that has
something to do with the culture I guess. So you mentioned in 1967 that Arizona? Right that came
about because the department chair at Arizona had been one of my professors at the University of
Washington he was on my committee. He was someone I liked a lot and he called me up one day
and told me that the University of Arizona had a new medical school starting and that he just
agreed to be chairman of the biochemistry department and what I liked to join him and I knew nothing
about Arizona at the time but I liked his name with Don Hanahan and he was in an area of biochemistry
that's quite different from mine he was an expert on biochemistry fats and lipids and the idea
of starting something new and there wasn't a matter of being interviewed of search committees
on that like that but basically just offered me a job over the phone and then I arranged to go out
and visit. This is in January 1967 and Kate went with me and we had to pay her expenses and it was
just a wonderful time. They put us up in a nice place and we got up in the morning and stepped
out the front door and picked a grapefruit for our breakfast off the tree that was going right next
to our front door and the dean and his wife took us out the dinner one night and in my years at
Yale I never met my dean the dean of the faculty of arts and sciences and here was the dean taking
us out the dinner and telling me how much they hoped that I would decide to go there it was a
it was a promotion of rank to be an associate professor big increase in salary and the opportunity
to help shape something because the medical school is brand new everyone in Arizona was excited
about the about the medical school that was starting and it just seemed like the right thing to do.
And did it about the expectation? Yes, you know I really enjoyed the time that we spent there we
were there for 10 and a half years and there was a lot of excitement in the first few years having
the feeling that we were helping to build the place up the medical school there was maybe a half
a mile from the main campus maybe a quarter mile it was a five minute bike ride or a 10 minute walk
and there was a little biochemistry group in the chemistry department that was pretty good and
the art department of medical school was small we had I think five or six faculty the whole time I was
there and so we merged and formed a joint graduate committee and biochemistry so that was one of the
things that I felt was a contribution on my part and the part of Don Hannah and that we wanted to
build bridges to the main campus whereas in other fields like microbiology there were barriers
that were built up and the bridges I think really were beneficial to the university and now they
have a combined university wide department that serves the main campus people and the medical
school people and mostly located on the main campus I think there are a couple people left in the
medical school building that focused on medical education.
So your obligation to stay in the fair enough from the old areas on it?
Yes they did of course teaching medical students was quite a different experience but I did
also were teach courses on the main campus and mostly the advanced undergraduate graduate
level course and some colleagues and I originated some graduate level courses I don't think I did
any graduate teaching a Yale except for the graduate lab class so I taught courses in biological
regulatory mechanisms and nucleic acids and so forth as well as teaching undergraduates and medical
students and but overall the I think the teaching load was a little bit I hate that term teaching
load the teaching obligation teaching opportunity was a little bit lighter than what it was at Yale
and so there's a little bit more time to get involved in research and again there was
building the department recruiting the other faculty members beginning to recruit graduate
students and getting funding for graduate student support and so forth you know it was a different
experience. So what kind of what was your line of research?
Well I continued with some of the some of the projects they were underway when I left
Yale and picked up some new ones but they for the most part they had to do with the end
of biology and regulation of DNA precursors. One thing that happened was that people involved in
T4 bacteriophage genetics had generated a large number of mutants that were available and there
were mutants in maybe 15 genes that were involved in DNA synthesis and it wasn't clear what the
biochemical functions of all these genes coded for and so I got involved in that a little bit
to what extent to run might some of these genes have to do with DNA precursors and metabolism
to what extent might they have to do with DNA replication itself and so at some stage I became
interested in the in the relationship between the synthesis of the four DNA precursors,
A, G, C and T to make it simplest and the replication apparatus because DNA replication is a very
rapid process. It's in bacteria or in phasor-affected bacteria the DNA chain will grow at something
like 7 or 800 dupletides per second. So I started thinking how can the enzymes that are making
the precursors throughout the cell, how can a channel precursors to DNA polymerase, the replication
apparatus fast enough to sustain this rate. So I started working on the premise that there was a
super molecular organization within the infected cell with the precursor enzymes physically
located close to the the repelation, the machinery that synthesized the DNA so that you could get
channeling of precursors to DNA replication sites and that was a pretty big part of my research
for several of the years I was there. I wanted to quite a bit of time that I was here,
but we picked up some lines of research on comparable questions in mammalian cells,
working in tissue culture. I also had a couple of students who worked on theses quite independently
on things that were quite different from anything that I did. One of them was sure that aging
was a question of gene expression and that you should be able to learn something about aging if
you do something about the kinetics of nucleic acid metabolism. He did a thesis that was partly
computational, partly biochemical on RNA metabolism that he published, one paper published independently
and one paper he put my name on as a curious gesture. After I came here, he joined my lab again.
He had a grant and he needed a site that he could work for, he could work fairly independently.
I remember that I'd let him have his own head. He was here for a couple of years and then
he got the idea of antisense as a potential drug and founded a company called Antivarals in his
recreation room here in Carvalos and then that turned into ultimately into AVI Biofarma,
which is a biotechnology company in Carvalos and eventually he left them and formed another
company, Gene Tools, which is in full on it and it's hugely successful. So even though all I
provided was a supporting environment at Arizona, it's turned out having a very nice spin-off here.
We're at about an hour, are you going to know, okay? Yeah, come on.
So this is your first experience of the self-less and you mentioned that experience of taking a great
experience. Yeah. We really enjoyed living there and both Kate and I are pretty enthusiastic
outdoors people and we found out that there's a lot more variety in the hours on of them. We
ever believed there was Tucson is bring by four mountain ranges and we did a lot of backpacking
there and we went camping in Mexico. It turned out there were some very nice
beach areas on the Gulf of California that we went and did weekend camping at and so we really
did everything we could to enjoy and profit from the southwest and we miss a lot of that. We
missed being able to get into the out of doors 12 months of the year very easily. But Tucson was
growing with very little planning and Tucson is one of the largest cities in the world.
It gets all of its water from underground and when the chance came to come to come here of course
it was professionally a very nice opportunity. We were happy to Tucson and I wondered do we
really want to move? But one of the features was how much longer is it going to mean up water
sustaining the population? How much longer are we going to have these beautiful desert environments
that really state the developments that are crowding on to? That all convinced us that we really enjoyed
the 10 years there but maybe it was time to go and every time we go back to Tucson we're horrified
at the additional growth that's occurred. You put the sabbatical of the US UCSD in 1973?
Right. Kate still criticizes me on occasion for not having taken a European sabbatical
end because our children were something like 12 and 14 at the time and they probably really
went a profit from a year in Europe. But I still had a fairly small research group and wanted to
stay in reasonable close touch with them and of course UCSD was a growing academic environment
with some superb people and we lived near the beach so it was a very nice living for the year.
I split the year between two different laboratories so I had two different kinds of experiences
and it was very nice. It was a good sabbatical.
The first six months I worked with a guy named Gordon Sado who was an expert on
culturing cells and maintaining their differentiated characteristics in culture and I wanted
to learn teacher culture because I wanted to give a little branch out with our interests into
mammalian systems so I could take what we were learning and microbial model systems and apply
them to mammalian or maybe human systems so I wanted to learn teacher culture. So I did a project
that had to do with growth factors in cell culture and then in the second six months I went to
the script's institutional oceanography where I had a very good friend who was an expert on the
biochemistry of early events in fertilization using the sea urchin and so fertilization is a
little comparable to the phage effect that is among the metabolic changes that occurs as a huge
turn on of a DNA synthesis and the cleavage cycles, the cell cleavage cycles are very fast so
so DNA genomes are reproduced in the order of half an hour so and so the question in my mind was
where do the precursors come from are they stored or is there a turn out of synthesis so that was
what I worked on in Dave's lab and it turned out that the sea urchin egg has huge supplies of
deoxyonucleuside triphosphates and then backup pools of the monophosphates and the triphosphates
so the egg is really geared to activate DNA synthesis very soon after fertilization and I thought
about going back and working about system a little bit of my own after I came here but to never
got around to it there were plenty of other things to do. What's the trend to straighten down there?
No, I don't think so. At the... Yeah, he was been at the Sock Institute. I've forgotten when I moved
there. I should know that because I reviewed the biography of Francis Quick just a few months ago
for an eternal and made fascinating reading. It was all these books. Yeah, in my review I wrote that
that this... I've been asked to review quite a few scientific books over the years. This is the
first one I actually read word for word cover for cover and cover. It's a redlock in novel but
I'm pretty sure that was before Kirk had moved to Sock. Over with here.
Was that right? I wish I'd known about that because I knew the name already. I knew he was a famous
historian of science, the recent historian of science.
Seymour Cohen was very interested in the early history of molecular biology.
He was pretty unpopular with the crowd in that field because he was so aggressively
pro-biochemical and didn't necessarily believe in genetics. Seymour Cohen was the first grad
with student of Irwin Shargaf. Shargaf who had promulgated the base composition
regularities that helped Watson and Quick develop their model. Shargaf had been very bitter about
being left out of credit for that. I think Seymour shared Shargaf's bitterness to some extent.
When the Nobel Prize was announced, I was in Seymour's lab and this is 1962.
It went to Watson and Quick and Maurice Wilkins. Seymour came into the lab and said,
well, if they were going to include Wilkins and the Nobel Prize, they should have included
Shargaf because his contribution was just substantial. I think he could make a pretty good case for
that. Of course, the Nobel Prize is limited to three awardees. I'm sure that didn't do very much
Irwin Shargaf's mood either.
He was a headman for the evidence for the full guy.
Yeah. In fact, Shargaf was the one who got me started thinking about Seymour Cohen
because my second year in graduate school, Shargaf came to Seattle and gave a series of lectures.
During the lectures, he talked about virus and do sins on. He talked about work by
student Seymour Cohen. I immediately went to the literature and started reading Seymour Cohen's
papers. I'd never heard them before. That was what got me fired up. The fact that Seymour was
Irwin Shargaf's student, but at some point, I met the
guy that was the chairman of biochemistry at Columbia when Shargaf had moved from Europe. I
think he was a refugee and the Columbia took him in. The chairman, his name was Hans Clarke.
He was quite a distinguished biochemist. Tell me what you're doing to Dr. Matthew. I said,
well, I'm a postdoc in the University of Pennsylvania. Who are you working with? I'm working with
Seymour Cohen. Oh, yes. Seymour. He's one of my boys, you know. It was very paternal or paternalistic.
So Seymour was Irwin Shargaf's student, but it turned out that when Seymour was working on his
postdoc or on his PhD, neither of them was working on their collect assets at the time. Seymour
is PhD thesis on long surf acting, which is a phospholipid. It wasn't until years later that both
Shargaf and Cohen independently started working on the click-hasted biochemistry.
There's something kind of fascinating about the personalities involved in the recent history of
science. Yeah. Yeah. Cohen something that he was definitely a pretty big figure in life.
He was. Yeah. He taught the famous course in comparative biochemistry. I don't
remember why I never sat in on the course. I should have, but he was very broadly based. He was
very rigorous in his thinking. And he had a pretty priculous personality. So he was definitely
a challenge to work for. But he was so broad and he had so many ideas that I think influenced
me to read pretty widely in science and trying to maintain and brought awareness. That's
helping a lot and writing a textbook. And also since I became a member of the editorial board of
the Journal of Biological Chemistry, I get sent papers to review that are way way outside of my
area because the editors know that I can sit down and read something. I got a paper to review a
couple years ago on the biochemistry body order if you believe that. Well, we converted this
a little bit in 1972. I see it in sounds like they made a pretty good opportunity to have the
primary reason in the horizon. Right. There was an interesting situation too. I didn't have any
real reasons to leave Arizona. As I said, you can always find things to feel uneasy about. But
I felt pretty well accepted on the campus. But I said my family was all still in the Pacific
Northwest. And so I kept my eye out for opportunities. And OSU advertised for a chair of the Department
of Biochemistry and Bio Physics and Science. So I wrote, sent my CV and eventually was asked for
my references. Voice, sent me names, references and eventually was asked to interview. And I had
enough information about the departments to know that it was a pretty good department. And they
sent me the data on the research funding of the faculty. And there were 14 faculty at the time.
Everyone except one had some kind of outside research funding. Publication records look pretty good.
So on the days when I was interviewed, it was a two day or two and a half day process.
I had a series of half hour talks with the faculty. And each one, I would say, you know, you've
got a good department. Why are you looking outside for your chair? You could fill the chairmanship
inside. And I got told pretty much the same thing by everyone. And of course, when you get
consistency, that's a pretty good sign. And what they said was, this is our only chance to bring
in a senior level faculty person who can bring in a funded research program and give a jump start
to our department's reputation. Because if we appointed an inside person to share them,
we'd have to fill the vacancy at the system professor level. So that made sense. And they said that
the department was in pretty good shape, scientifically, and personally everyone got along,
which really seemed to be the case. And so what they wanted was someone who was a pretty active
scientist and teacher who was willing to do some administration and leadership. And that was
sort of how I saw myself. I knew by that time I could probably handle the administrative details
of being a department chair, but it wasn't the be all and end all of my existence. And so it was
a pretty good fit. And then after a few weeks after the interview, the dean called up to offer me
the job. It was my 40th birthday. And so it seemed like a, it seemed like a, an omen of some kind.
And that was kind of amusing too, because I put in a call, oh, this happened later on. So I got
the offer. And then Kate and I were invited back to visit again in this time. It was a recruitment
visit. And it was very pleasant again. And then went back home and after a while thought things
over and decided I would accept the job. So I put in a call to the dean and he was out of the office.
And he would call back. And I sat there thinking I was about to make a decision that would affect
the rest of my life. And the phone rang and I thought it was Dean Proust calling me back.
No, it was the guy from the biochemistry department of the University of California Davis
asking if I'd like to be considered for the chairmanship with the department there.
And I said you got a great department, but I think it's a little too late.
The main priority for me to keep my research program visible on
productive. It's quite a job to move a research program. I knew that the department would be in
pretty good shape. There were a few things that needed to be done.
You know, I knew I could handle whatever teaching I need to do here.
But not all the people that were working with me in Tucson chose to come. So I had to
had to punch more people. And my major research grant had, I don't remember a year and a half
or so to run. And I just wanted to make sure that I'd got enough papers out during that time.
So I'd be competitive. It was grants were already this now in the late 1970s.
The grant situation was beginning to tighten up. So that was my first priority. It worked out pretty well.
Did the administrative pressure exchange over time?
Yes. But actually getting back to priorities for just a minute,
there were some things in the department early on that I felt should get taken care of.
One was the fact that a graduate student's
there was hardly any money in the department to support teaching assistance. So there wasn't much
state money that would support students who weren't committed to allow. So almost all the students
came on research assistantships which meant they were committed to the lab whose research grant
was paying their assistantship. And I thought that a first year grad with program should have
opportunity for students to come on committed. I thought it was a great strength that students
could come here and start right to work with a person that they wanted to work with but that
many students come without a specific set of interest and they should have an opportunity to go
through rotations. So pretty high priority for me early on was to get an NIH training grant that
would provide funds for tuition and stipends for half a dozen students or so so that we could bring
out a few and give them a year to look around and then go on to research assistantships. And my first
attempt was unsuccessful. That was kind of interesting too because we got kind of a mediocre
score on the grant application and really kind of a snotty critique in which the whoever reviewed
the grant said the training record of the faculty doesn't seem to be particularly strong.
Most of the graduate seemed to have taken jobs in industry and I wrote to the NIH and I said
what is this? It seems to me that Congress which funds the NIH might have second thoughts about
the training and program of industrial positions are seeing a second rate. So I'm going to revise
the application and I'd like to have a site visit so you can see what we have out here. And so the
second time we had a site visit and we got the grant and had it for two or three cycles. So that
was a sort of an institutional priority for me. And then in 1981, so this was an opportunity
to sort of dump in my lap but it was an institutional priority for me. The dean called me in and
said that the MJ Murdoch Charitable Trust, you know about the Murdoch Trust, this is a large foundation
that was created from the estate of Jack Murdoch who was one of the founders of Tectronics.
Murdoch died prematurely in an airplane accident and he left most of the state entrusted as a
foundation to support educational, charitable and community organizations of the Civil War.
And they used to give project grants to faculty here but apparently the trust had told President
Wicker that they now wanted to focus their grants more on large multi-person projects that
represented institutional priorities. And so the dean and the president and others then decided
that he was time to make a push in molecular biology and so they called me in as the person to
sort of the point person to write something up. And it was clear, that was right, it was very much
a time to make a push even though that doesn't pretty good people scattered around the university here
in that area. And it was clear to me that there's multi-departmental cooperation is very strong
on this campus and so whatever we did should be in a multi-departmental, multi-discipline or
framework. So I proposed that the university create something that would be called the Center
of Virginia Research and that the grant then fund three positions and pay their salaries and
start-up costs for two years with the commitment by the university that their salaries would be
continued at the end of that two years and that the search would be conducted in a multi-departmental
framework. There was old money also for project grants for the faculty that was here.
And so then when the grant was funded we had a we had a multi-departmental search that
brought three excellent people in. One who came to our department is now the chairman of our
department, Gary Merrill. One who went to botany, Carol Rubin, and one who went to microbiology and
that's Dennis Ruby who's now the chief scientific officer at Seagal Farm of Sugals. So very good people.
In the meantime the people in the ag school wanted to form a biotechnology institute or biotechnology
center and President Wicker told them that there wasn't a that the campus wasn't big enough to
have two competing centers and areas related to biotechnology and they'd better work with us.
So we made the center. I mean I had no idea it would grow to something that encompassed
the whole campus the way it did but it turned out to be very successful. And in the first several
years I think 1985 the center had caught on so well that the legislature appropriated a pretty
fierce chunk of change as continuing a continuing budget for the quite that time with the CGRB.
So that was something else that worked out pretty well and then I served the director of the
center for a year and a half or so after the first director left the fairly abruptly.
What did the center stand for?
Well it continued to get bigger and stronger and after I resigned as director
because I couldn't handle two administrative jobs and still keep research lab going and keep my
teaching going and so there was sort of an interim appointment made while there was an outside
search and Russ mines came from the University of Nebraska and he built it up a bit and then he
retired and then a really big push came when Jim Carrington was brought in and of course he had a
superb research program and so I think his program attracted a lot of other people
and departments all over the campus were beginning to use molecular biology techniques.
So the center and then Jim changed the focus of the center with a big emphasis on
genomics and computational biology. In fact the name of the center was changed. I didn't realize
this for a couple years. It's still the CGRB but now instead of being the center for gene
research and biotechnology it's the center for genomics research and bio computing and so five or
six years ago there was a university wide hiring initiative in genomics and bio computing and there
was another MOLI departmental search that I think brought five faculty members and they're
outstanding people. One of them is Michael Freitag who came to the art department and his
office is right next door to mine and one is Todd Mockler and botanates and extremely well.
I think he left Carrington left this year to become a president and a director of the Danforth
foundation in St. Louis. I just learned a dare to the Mockler went with him but it's really
outstanding people came and the focus to the center changed and it's well rooted in the
university. The central service lab which the center maintains carries out multine investigator
procedures, nucleic acid sequencing and oligopeptide synthesis that it's been doing for years but it
also has a very large computational and second generation DNA sequencing capability grafted on so
it's got bigger and stronger over the years. So getting back to the administrative
responsibilities, how did they shift over the years? They shifted in that it got harder and harder
to get money and there was a little bit more administration that had to get done. So the first year or
two I was here, one of my colleagues got money and one of his grants, $100,000 to buy an electron
microscope. This is one art department that's telling him what are your hall and he came to me and
said we need a room to put the electron microscope in and I said well I guess we're going to have to
see the Dean so we don't see Dean Krauss and it was maybe a 15 minute conversation and he found
$50,000 to renovate some space on the first floor to Wunderland so we got the pretty substantial
amount of money on the basis of a one short conversation. Getting money became harder and harder
and at one point so our department has always been very heavily involved with the Environmental
Health Science Center. This is a center that's funded with a core grant from the National Institute
of Environmental Health Sciences and it was originally headquartered basically on what used to be
the Department of Agricultural Chemistry and that again is a center that's become bigger and
stronger over the years and at some point when the previous director retired Don Reed who was
an art department became the director so we were heavily involved with that center and one of the
hardest things for me in my last several years of being department share was accumulating competitive
startup packages when we wanted to recruit a faculty member. That's one thing to get us
a salary line but around the country the amount of money you had to put together to track someone
getting larger and larger because a new assistant professor couldn't count on getting his or her
first grant funded and needed some money from day one and I remember one of the people who came in
as Vice President for Research which is of course one of the major sources that we would go to.
I think I've suppressed his name because I dislike him so much. Somehow or another he never caught
onto the idea that the discretionary funds he had as a disposal one of the highest priorities
of them should be contributions toward setup funds and Don Reed who was still the director of the
the the EHSC and I talked or so blue in the face before we got a token contribution from and
and we were just really irritated and I remember another interesting episode we had with the
Environmental Health Science Center when Don Reed became director of the center this was in the
early 1980s he also was pretty expansionist he wanted to build and solidify the EHSC
and this sort of parenthetical but in my opinion one of the strengths of Oregon State I said
something about the Inter-Departmental Cooperation you have strong individual departments but these
you have these centers that that span departmental boundaries we have the CGRB the EHSC and of
course the line is Pauling Institute and I think all of these centers have done nothing but good
things for the university by bringing in more research so one thing that Don Reed wanted to do
was to use the funds he had in the center to establish two or three new
faculty positions that would be partly funded by the EHSC and partly funded by university funds
so one of the positions would be in our department if you wanted to get someone who was
using cell culture to study basically areas related to environmental toxicology
and the dean at the time said well our department was overstaffed already that we had
too many faculty positions for the number of credit hours that we taught you know the kind of
thinking that administrators go through and of course both Don and I saw this as a great
opportunity to strengthen the department research wise and bring in some more money to the department
and Don was pretty aggressive so he set up a so he set up a employment a meeting with President
Luther and six or eight of a sat around a table including Don and myself and George Keller who
was the vice president for research at the time and Dean Sir Gajaro Dean of the College of
Science and the president maybe one or two others and Dean Sir Gajaro went through his routine that
the department was overstaffed already and he couldn't justify putting even a part of a salary into
our budget under the circumstances and then Don Reed gave his pitch I don't think I said much
of anything I was just there for support Don got all the negative brownie points from the dean
and at the end of Don's talk part of the record said well it sounded like a pretty good proposal
let's go ahead with it and I thought the dean was going to cry and so at that from that point on
Don Reed's name was poison in the College of Science but it worked out very well he brought in
David Barnes who's no longer here but that position was established and we have got a research
facility that's helped the whole campus community and then he brought in Dale Mausbaugh in what
Hannah was at at Cam that Mausbaugh had a superb research program until he died very young in 2004
but the idea that you could use Center funds to strengthen research programs within departments
in the Strankland Inter-Departmental Cooperation has been a keynote for the CDRB the EHSC
and the Linus Paulingance in fact the really history of the Linus Paulingance is pretty interesting too
Don Reed was acting director of the Institute but we had a search for director
and I was chair of the search committee that brought both right here
and that worked out extremely successfully both it's so good and the people he'd brought
in are just outstanding but I think the only time I ever had a one-on-one conversation with
President Brisser was shortly with while this was all underway I think I don't remember whether
balls fry to arrive yet or when we're still having research but of course it was concerned
all over the campus about LPI how it would drain research resources away from the administration
and and of course the the Linus Paulingance Institute in California was was pretty mixed
with scientific quality and that was a bit of a concern but John Byrne really pushed the
whole thing it was his legacy to the university and we were and so Brisser and I were walking
together from some function and it was just the two of us and he said what do you think about
this move of the Linus Paulingance Institute anyway is obviously was pretty negative about the
whole thing and I said it doesn't make it I said it doesn't make any difference what you or I
think about it it's happening anyway and at the time I think I was one of the cautious ones
without a tube but I'd become nothing but a supporter because we were so fortunate in getting
balls to come here is our first choice I thought the recruitment would be very difficult because
the LPI occupied space that our department occupied before we moved to Agony Life Sciences
and it was pretty it was the space was pretty trashed but but both saw that it could work
they did a little bit of renovation and of course they said that a new building would be something
it would be fairly high on the priority scale but it took a long time but it worked so you asked
about the administrative load the other thing that happened in those last several years was the
planning of the Agony Life Sciences building that took a lot of time and then in the initial planning
I became aware that there were documents in the university that had five levels of space
assignment depending on what kind of department or college you were in and of course
agricultural forestry were on the highest level number square feet per FTE of lab space square
feet per FTE for office space and science was a level below ag and so we started having our first
planning meetings and it was mostly ag people of course because of the Agony Life Sciences
and biochemistry bio physics was put into the department sort of accidentally and the way I
understood it was the administration was having trouble assembling funding for the building
and it's all seriously but the way I heard it was that George Keller said well we don't have enough
pizzazz in the building we have range science we have ag administration we have horticulture they're all
perfectly justifiable but we need to put some of our environmental science we need to put some
more biotechnology in there and apparently Dean Horn was at the planning meeting he said well
you know biochemistry and bio physics is heavily involved in both the biotechnology and environmental
health science so we were moved in very quickly but then it turned out that they wanted to assign
space on the science level assignment and I figured if we're moving to the new building we need to
have the same kind of space allocation that the other departments in the building had
is about that time about that time a friend of mine who was chairman of the search committee
for Dean of science at Penn State invited me to come to look at the job
and after I looked at it it was I didn't want the job but it was clear that they wanted me
so I went to talk to Graham Spaniard of course he would come here from Penn State and now
as back there is one of the most successful university presidents in the country and Graham was
was very excited to hear that they wanted me to go to Penn State he didn't talk to me at all
about what can we do to keep you he wanted to know a lot about what was happening at Penn State
and so forth but he did eventually you know what would it take to keep you and I had two things in
mind that would benefit the department and one of them was space allocation the new building I said
they're basically trying us to talk and sound on space we have adequate space in one of
the spaces kind of second rate quality was but if we're going to be asked to help plan a new
building and move into space we need to we need to be assured that if we don't have to accept any
less square footage what we have now so he put that on a letter that helped me a lot is
we'll have to be the planning process but that took a lot of time to
were there any major shifts in your research during the years?
yes not major I've always always been involved in in nuclear time the oxygen nuclear time in
DNA precursor in the zymology and biochemistry yeah I can tell you look yeah the answer is yes I'll
get to that in a minute but I'll tell you another story about the new building that you might
find entertaining this has to do with the administrative load and you have to watch these guys all the time
actually two stores one time we were in a meeting in the administration building and
and they we were being told that there wasn't enough money to build a building with size that
was being discussed in the beginning and we were going all around the table what can we do about
this cutback and that cutback and it was it was getting pretty late in the country in the evening
you know six o'clock six three or so and the guy named Ed Cote was the vice president for the
administration of the time and he was kind of a laughing stock in the faculty and he was getting
more and more impatient he basically said finally hey it's getting late here let's just
lop off a floor and we can leave so that's solidified our review about Ed Cote and somehow it ended
up that the building was built I think the university got a bargain it's a very good building he
was done with the funds available but at one point the architect told me that we've we've built
a prototype laboratory so you and your colleagues can go over look at it look at the cabinets look
at the shell look at the bench top look at the utility and see what it looked like I said we're
as well it's in in Morland Hall there's a member of the psychology faculty
Bill Smotheren who does physiological work and and he needed a he needed an upgrade to his lab so
we've built that as a prototype lab and you can go and see what it looks like and so we went over
and it did its nice lab and so we could see what kind of counter top they were going to have
and the new building and so forth and then it occurred to me to ask someone hey where the money
come from to do this it turns out that Bill Smotheren had been offered a job in another institution
and and he needed in order to stay one of the things that he needed was an upgrade to his lab so
we went to his dean the dean went to the then Provost and somehow things that come about so that
money was siphoned out of our building project to build this guy's lab and so we raised hell about
and so they had to find the money from somewhere else and put it back into the building project
so you had to be on your toes all the time about these guys so getting back to research
I had a graduate student in the early who finished in about 1982 who did his thesis on
the DNA precursor supply for the mitochondrial adrenal I'd seen a paper in the literature that
suggested that the mitochondrial genome is fed by a distinct precursor pool that might be generated
within the mitochondrial and so Rick Besswick did his thesis on the series of experiments and
indicated yes indeed the pools were physically distinct and regulatory sense as well and
then that sort of sat there until the late 1990s and another grader was student joined our group
she was a song Chinese student who wanted to follow up on that work he was a
head medical degree from China and the number of diseases had been described that have
that have genetic effects within the mitochondria and some of them are mutations within the
mitochondrial genome some of them are mutations of the nuclear genome that encode proteins that
are transported into mitochondria and function there and so there's some very interesting
diseases and of course now there's also the the idea that accumulation of mutations in the
mitochondrial genome is partly responsible both for cancer and aging and since we knew that
aspects of DNA precursor metabolism are mutagenic determinants that is metabolic
derangement but if you will deoxyneucleotide metabolism can affect the mutation rate we
wanted to learn more about the mitochondrial pools of DNA precursors where they came from how they
were regulated and how this might affect mutation rate it turns out the mutation rate for the mitochondrial
genome is much higher than it is for the nuclear genome and why should this be so she way did his
thesis on this and he was one of my last graduate students to finish but by the time he started
publishing papers from his thesis we began to get some notice for this so I got funding
actually after I retired and was hoping I'd be able to keep research funding going because this
was turning out to be a pretty productive line of research so so in fact that has been the
total of our research since about 2003 and and I had pretty decent funding for that and during that
time the three graduate students that I had at the time I retired in 2002 they took two or three four
years to finish and they were done but after that I kept my lab going with a technician and a
postdoc and one or two undergrad was supposed to the time now I decided to to let my funding
expire and what there's a new faculty member in our department is going to take over our lab
so my last grant expires the end of the year but for the last year it's taken the knowledge and
the background I have and the oxygenucleotide metabolism just applied it to mammalian cells and
mitochondrial metabolism. The last sort of big topic I like to talk about is your textbook by chemistry.
Right so what was the process in which you and Ben hold this entity we're going to do this?
In 1983 and 1984 there were two major texts that came out
and we have two sort of advanced level undergraduate courses BB-450 451 which most students take as a
two-quarter sequence and then BB-49491 and 492 and these can both be taken as undergrad or graduate
and these two books came out and one of them we assigned to the 450 course and one we adopted
for the 492 course and they're both terrible and at some point in the spring
it was eating my lunch and they in my office and a publisher's representative came in and I
sort of set my sandwich aside and so I told them how disappointed we were with all the textbooks
they were on the market and he said well you know so much about what's wrong with all these books
you ought to be writing your own book and I said are you crazy I don't have the time or the expertise
about the whole book said well get a co-author. Well I was about to go on sabbatical leave
to Sweden and I thought well you know maybe I could write in the evening working a lab during the
day so it's not a completely crazy idea and I was talking to my colleague Bob Becker about this
and he said well why don't you talk to Ken Van Holt he's talked about writing textbooks from
time to time and Ken and I had taught graduate level courses together I knew he was extremely
articulate and brilliant scientist and he had a good sense of humor and also was much more of a
physical biochemist than I am his PhD that's my physical chemistry so I went and talked to Ken
and he said well I'd have to be crazy to even think about something like this but yes I am
interested so we went down and visited the publisher and talked to our editor, the woman who would
be our editor and she said that each of us should write a sample chapter and we should write a
chapter outline and a perspective sample chapter and she bought each of us a compact computer this
is just before Macintosh came out but there were there were slightly portable computers so I
took one with me to Stockholm and by the time I finished writing my sample chapter I thought this
is more work than I want to let myself in for but we sent the material in and in December Diane
called up she said the reviewers all liked what we've written and they thought we ought to go ahead
so they wanted to sign us for contract so I thought oh god what do I do now and I called Ken
and he said oh yeah I think it's terrific let's go so there was no alternative and we went ahead
with it and many times during the writing process I thought I was crazy to get involved in this
if I could quit I would but in retrospect I'm glad that we stuck with it and it took a long time
because it was 1984 that they first started talking to us about the book it was really 85 when
we signed the contract and then I had a lot of things that got me behind schedule when I came
back from sabbatical and we didn't really plan to end our work on an any kind of schedule basis
till spring or so of 1986 but we had the first draft done maybe in spring of 88 no it must have
been eighty-six I don't remember the dates now because it took a year or so to produce the book
after the after the chapter drafts were done so the whole thing was about a almost five year
process and the subsequent additions were much easier
was it a bit more process to establish the point of view of the two authors that you're going to be writing the book down?
Actually that was the easiest part. Ken and I split up responsibility for chapters very easily
we agreed to read each other chapters I did most of the metabolism he did most of the structural
biochemistry and we sort of split the molecular biology the genetic biochemistry and
the editors were very concerned about merging our our prose styles I think we did pretty well
although now that I'm I'm writing some for our fourth edition which he's not involved in I'm
writing some rewriting some chapters he wrote and I'm seeing some differences between his writing
style and mine but the difficulty we had in the first edition was some pretty spirited arguments
with our editors they kept a pretty heavy hand on us and we disagreed with him pretty frequently
but they ended up being pretty good friends and we had a different editorial team each with each
of the editions but that was where the energy came out but Ken and I had nothing but a good
relationship the one thing that was a disappointing was that he spends almost half the year at his
summer home in Woods Hole that he established when he was at the University of Illinois before he came
here and that's chooses so it wasn't always a matter of just walking down the hall if I wanted to talk
to him but he worked out pretty well it did pretty well I can't tell you how much
the percentage of the market had captured but the publisher very pleased the terms of the royalties
we were very pleased and I've been told by quite a few people I mean this is not something I should
be talking about but I've been told that that is the most clearly written book on the market
and I know it it it brought us a lot of attention I know when I was in sabbatical leave in Sweden
I got a call one day and from someone at the University of Uppsala they wanted me to come
and meet with a group of their biochemistry teachers to tell them my thoughts about teaching biochemistry
I gave a talk in South Africa a few years ago and they're biochemistry meeting and the
students were coming up and wanting to be photographed with me because they'd used our book so a lot
of things happened that were very gratifying to the ego so from that standpoint I guess our book
was received well enough that it was worth the effort and worth the effort after the project I
thought was dead after the 30th edition was done that it was worth picking up for the fourth edition
as you look back on your career what are some of the things you have published of
I guess the first thing is the fact that I trained 35 PhD students and most of them have done
very well on their careers and that's like being a parent and most of them stated enough contact
that I had the feeling that I that I made a difference in their lives another thing that I've
been satisfied with is maintaining a balance of teaching and research through all the positions I've
had because I always enjoyed teaching I'm pretty enthusiastic about the field I like to know
what's going on the field I like to explain it to others whether it's in writing or speaking
and I like to set an example for colleagues who might be focused only on their research
that you can be a successful research scientist and still maintain personal communication with
students with colleagues with people in other departments on the campus that science can be a
social activity so I would say the breadth of interest and association that had something else I
take satisfaction in and being able to say funded for years in a very difficult increasingly
difficult environment and the book I mean that's pretty big part of my life put pretty big strain
in our family situation for a long time but now Kate is just she just as supportive about the
whole thing as I am she likes it when I come home and tell her stories about the experience that we had
and so it's been a big plus also. Is there anything to read next that we should pass on?
Well yeah I guess there's always been the thought about what again parallel lies parallel universe
universes what if I go on into medicine and that's hit it several times when I was in college
trying to decide which way to go of course my father was a doctor I thought the world of him
and I talked and I catered and you know maybe we could go out of practice together
and that could have been fun but dad was very good about not putting pressure on he said it was
my decision whether to go on to science or medicine and you asked about the Reed College culture
earlier and Premeds were sort of frowned on as being grade lovers even though Reed gave grades
but the students weren't we weren't told what the grades were and the idea was to make you less grade
causes but the Premeds were a little more narrow and they were interesting and I saw there was
something about the culture that the that the highest level of acceptance was the people that wanted
to go on into university and college professors so that helped and then I was pointed in that direction
but when I went to Arizona and started teaching medical students I realized that biochemistry in that
context is a lot different and my father actually never actually conveyed to me the intellectual
stimulation of medicine as a multi departmental scientific activity it was partly that he was in
and practiced he was an internist but a lot of his patients were they just had routine troubles
that didn't give him much stimulation so he didn't convey that part of it but once I had to learn
to teach biochemistry in a way that medical students would accept and once I started
interacting with him the college I realized that that medicine is a lot different from what I thought
was and so at some point after I'd been there a few years early 70s I read that the University of
Miami had created a fast track MD program for PhDs in the biomedical sciences you could finish
a MD degree in a year and a half to two years I was pretty interested in this so I applied for it
and it was accepted and then I went to talk to the department chairman the idea being that
one of the years I could get partial support by being on sabbatical leave and then we'd use our
own resorts for the rest and when I told him about it he looks though he'd been kicked in the stomach
and then he he talked to my colleagues which I always felt was improper I thought that my
conversation was just one on one but after a week he said that the department had decided they
they really didn't want me to do this well obviously I could have done it anyway but I would have
had to resign I could have resigned you know I thought it over and by that time our children were
date and ten we were pretty well settled and two son and there wasn't any and I enjoyed what I
was doing there wasn't any real there wasn't any reason that I had to do this but I've always wondered
what it would have been like if I'd if I'd had a current medicine would I have gone into medical
research or would I have been a primary in practice would I have gotten the intellectual stimulation
would I've enjoyed the kind of breadth the awareness of what's happening and cutting edge science
and all the rest of it being ice if you could live too large but that's something I just have to
live with I guess so obviously we're also very proud of our two children Lawrence who was as I
said was born very shortly after our marriage and then Anne and was born a couple years later
Lawrence ended up going to the University of Washington for a PhD in biochemistry so he was
in the same department I was and the department had changed a lot since then he's now out of
science but he got a great start to his career he did a post-doc in Sweden and then a second post
doc in the Sock Institute and he did a piece of work that made him quite well known he had
four excellent faculty offers and he was an assistant professor at the University of Michigan
for several years and he had an epiphany and now he's a teacher in the Waldorf school system
and then we'll go into detail about that but he is much happier doing that than he ever was
as a university faculty member and our daughter graduated from Oregon State with a degree in psychology
and no clue to what she wanted to do and she happened to talk to a
naval recruiter on campus and ended up going to naval officer candidate school after she graduated
and becoming an incident and she had a she did very well in the Navy but she ended up secretly
getting married to an enlisted man under her command and that was a no-no in the Navy and when
they found out they were both in trouble and again making a long story short they both left the Navy
and the Anne was in the reserve she got promoted in the reserve so she was in good standing as far
as the Navy was concerned but they had two children and she was basically sock her mom
until her two daughters were in college and then she went back and got a degree as a
paralegal assistant so she's working in that field so both of our children are doing things they
enjoy a great deal each of them has two children who've done very well and so that's something
that Keaton I can look at with some satisfaction also